ich möchte damit starten dass einfach
die tradition also ich habe selber eine
tradition gemacht das heißt dass man
sich als frau als mann fühlt und dann
der meinung ist dass es einen selber
zukünftig besser ist das durchzuziehen
dass es einfach nicht für alle der
richtige weg ist also viele sind der
meinung sie müssen tradition ihren
danach ist alles super und das ist der
wunderwaffe das alles funktioniert und
danach irgendwie nach ein paar jahren
hormone oder nacht pubertäts blockern
usw stellen sie dann für sich selber
fest dass es die falsche entscheidung
war und viele trauen sich dann aber auch
nicht hier in den eigenen fehler
zuzugeben oder sind dann weiterhin in
der ihre trans rolle selber drinnen weil
sie einfach nicht irgendwie darüber
hinweg kommen
sozusagen also nicht zugeben wollen dass
es eben dass sie fehler gemacht haben
und
genau
ich bin dann selber in der messenger
gruppe drin wo es halt um die 20 die
transaktion ihre rinnen jetzt
tatsächlich schon gibt und wir probieren
und zu machen wir das thema
auszutauschen weil viele auch dass die
schwierigkeit haben wenn sie haben mit
den männlichen hormonen zum beispiel
aufhören dass ihn keine weiblichen
hormone mehr verschrieben werden dass da
dann plötzlich gutachten gefordert
werden die vorher nicht gefordert worden
sind bei dem ersten weg und
jetzt möchte ja die bundesregierung
neues gesetz machen das heißt dann dass
selbstbestimmung des gesetz- und bei
diesen selbstbestimmung das gesetz solle
jeder bürger einfach zum standesamt hin
gehen können und dort sein neues seinen
neuen geschlechts wunsch angeben können
das heißt dass frauen können plötzlich
rechtliche männer werden und aus männern
rechtliche frauen und es gibt ja ich
auch quer beauftragten und viele aus der
mlg die community haben
befürchtungen was dieses gesetz angeht
zum beispiel dass viele lesben viele
schwule viele bisexuelle
transitional könnten also genau in diese
rolle dann rein fallen könnten weil sie
sich einfach als frauen zb untypisch als
kaufverhalten oder männer die sicherheit
und typisch männlich also eher weiblich
behalten und genau also gibt's
eigentlich viel widerspruch aber der
wehrbeauftragte wird leider diesen
leuten nicht zu da gibt es zum beispiel
wde das women's national international
oder die elg bei lyoness da gibt es auch
in deutschland abzweig davon oder latz
reloaded das
das aktionszentrum reloaded das waren
die alten listen aus den 70er jahren die
jetzt der meinung sind wieder ihren
verein zurück ergründen zu müssen damit
sie eben eine opposition zu diesem
selbstbestimmtes gesetzt haben sie bei
sich selbst bei ihrer eigenen geschichte
das gefühl gehabt dass wenn man
vielleicht mehr aufgeklärt wäre oder
sogar mehr kontrollen stattgefunden mehr
gespräche noch es vielleicht gar nicht
gemacht hätten zum beispiel sich die
brüste abzunehmen ich glaube ehrlich
gesagt das ist schwierig gewesen wäre
also tatsächlich bei den aspekten idee
hatte mirjam ich denke ich schon noch
davon abhalten können also ich hatte
tatsächlich gar nicht mal ein
vorgespräch bei dem krankenhaus was ich
jetzt aber nachträglich leider nicht
mehr nachweisen kann aber ich hatte
damals für die krankenkassen was
unterschrieben dass sich dieses
vorgespräch hatte was hat nicht
stattgefunden hat
also wenn dann über aufklärung gewesen
wäre dann hätte ich womöglich die massen
nicht gemacht aber ich glaube von den
hormonen hätte man mich ehrlich gesagt
nicht abbringen können weil ich da
einfach in dieser transkripte damals
drinnen war wo sehr viele leute eben
tradition irrt haben die ich für mich
als irgendwie als vorbild gesehen habe
also ja sehr männlich auftretende frauen
und ich habe einfach ein vorbild gesucht
weil ich ja selber in bayern groß
geworden bin wo alles sehr sehr
konservativ ist und weil sie frauen
geliebt haben haben sie dann gedacht sie
müssten eigentlich zum mann werden genau
genau und ich habe heute einfach diese
vorbilder gesucht und wir haben halt
alle gerade transaktion irrt und dadurch
war es halt besonders schwierig weil man
zur sicherheit vorbilder wie man 20
jahren vielleicht sein könnte und die
nehmen aber gerade alles schon
testosteron und haben jede mastektomie
und man erzählt sich das hat auch jede
woche wo die dann gerade auf ihrem
traditions- weg gerade neu angekommen
sind und ja das animiert einen natürlich
auch diesen weg zu gehen obwohl es einem
selber womöglich gar nicht weiterhilft
dann kriegen ja jetzt auch harsche
kritik wenn sie ihre geschichte erzählen
habe ich mitbekommen
auch im netz warum
ja das ist eine gute frage also ich
glaube eigentlich einmal dieses negativ
hinterfragt das halt diese transaktion
einem halt irgendwie die glückseligkeit
sozusagen bringt also es ist fast schon
wie eine neue art von religion und man
darf das ganze halt nicht hinterfragen
also wenn man einfach schon gesagt dass
biologie real ist also dass das
biologische nur zwei geschlechter gibt
dann wird man halt runter gemacht wie
man an der biologin in berlin jetzt
sehen konnte haben deren vortrag erstmal
gecancelt wurde und sie konnten dann
nachträglich noch mal nachholen also es
gibt einfach jesus diese trennung im
englischen also ist es ja sex und gender
die gibt's halt in deutschland nicht so
wirklich weil alle halt immer nur vom
geschlecht reden und es ist ja selbst im
englischen schwierig diese diskussion zu
führen um deutschen wurzeln noch
schwieriger weshalb beide sachen einfach
nur einen begriff gibt herr frank sie
sind jetzt natürlich kein experte dafür
aber wenn sie jetzt hören dass
beispielsweise schon bei sechs bis
achtjährigen es erleichtert werden soll
hormonen blogger zu verschreiben ist es
eigentlich körperverletzung also bei
kindern schon ich habe patienten diesen
transsexuell und das ist nicht an
erzogen oder so sondern die das sind
menschen die kommen auf die welt und
fühlen sich im falschen körper und das
wird nur zum teil gelindert auch durch
die operation
und diese menschen brauchen toleranz ja
die sind früher so gehänselt worden wenn
sie dann frauenkleider tragen dass man
und so weiter
aber das ist ein heißes thema es ist ein
ernstes thema und es ist mir im moment
viel zu marktschreierisch und die gefahr
besteht tatsächlich und bei ihm war das
offensichtlich der fall dass die
beratung nicht gut war oder so nehmen
sie zwar hätte man vielleicht erkannt
dass sie pflicht zu frauen hingezogen
fühlen und eigentlich überhaupt nicht
transsexuell sind so würde jetzt mal so
höre ich das ein bisschen raus also es
war eine fehldiagnose die geht es zu
einem eingriff geführt hat er nicht mehr
reversibel ist und ich fürchte wenn man
es in der art und weise betreibt wie es
gerade betreibt das viele solche
fehlentwicklungen stattfinden und leute
dann quasi ihr ganzes leben auch zum
teil ruiniert wird also es ist ein sehr
ernstes thema es braucht sehr viel
toleranz aber es sollte reise
stattfinden und es sollte nicht quasi so
sagen dass ich leute über dieses thema
politisch gesellschaftlich ja soll ich
sagen profilieren und dann wieder
aufmerksamkeit zu erhaschen nein es ist
ein ernstes thema es gehört in die
sprechstunde und man muss natürlich
sagen
sie haben die ersten
aktivisten die haben sicherlich dafür
gesorgt dass in der gesellschaft eine
viel höhere toleranz da war und sie
wurden hier teilweise auch durch
intoleranz sind die entscheidung rein
getrieben ja sonst hätten sich einfach
getraut einfach so zu sagen wie sie sind
und wir müssen das wort toleranz ist
sehr sehr wichtig aber wir müssen das
bitte schön leise dies gewesen mit gehen
ja hier würde ich mitgehen also erstmal
wirklich respekt fairness jahre lang
absolut ich bin da wirklich beeindruckt
wie sie das auch erzählen und und auch
selbstkritisch so ein bisschen sehen und
und ich finde was sie gerade gesagt
haben die toleranz in der gesellschaft
die offenheit in der gesellschaft
solchen menschen gegenüber die solche
empfindungen und gefühle haben ich
glaube das wird uns alle voranbringen
und dass man diese dinge das sage ich
jetzt mal als privatperson im privaten
im heimlichen mit sich ausmachen muss
ich glaube das sollte der vergangenheit
angehören und insofern da bin ich einer
meinung mit ihnen herr frank dass das
toleranz in der gesellschaft offenheit
in der diskussion auch die tür ist dass
man dann auch diese
beratungsmöglichkeiten in anspruch
nehmen kann die dringende notwendigkeit
dass er gerade immer so dass zum
beispiel männer hat die frauenkleidung
tragen dann heißt das direkt dass er
seine transfers muss aber gar nicht und
das kann ja genauso sein das ist ein
mann ist der gerne kleidung trägt und da
schließt sich gerade das fenster oder
wenn eine frau halt einfach sehr sehr
burschikos ist und gerne keine ahnung
hat wie sport macht oder so was in die
richtung dann heißt es immer jetzt schon
du bist ja so burschikos du bist dann
geht es ja man verloren gegangen wie
wärs denn hier mit testosteron und ich
denke halt dass dieses fenster derzeit
um einiges kleiner wird darauf
weist man halt auch die alten aktivisten
hinaus den 70er und 80er jahren weil die
haben nämlich die befürchtung dass sie
selber als kinder und jugendliche heute
tradition ihren würden also wenn sie
heute leben würden und gerade das ist
halt auch die schwierigkeit an diesem
selbstbestimmung gesetz das 14 jährige
dann tatsächlich schon entscheiden
können sollen was dann ihr jeweiliger
personen stand ist was ihr jeweilige
vorname sein so sie finde es viel zu
früh genau das heißt er jetzt immer dass
dieses gesetz total getrennt ist von den
medizinischen
maßnahmen wie zb ich kann halt von
meinen geschichte wiederum reden wo ich
da mir dass das darum besorgt habe und
zwar ohne gutachten und direktheit
meinem frauenarzt der mir das
verschrieben hat die krankenkasse hat
ist übernommen danach hat sich bei der
masse keiner mehr darum gekümmert
ob ich denn überhaupt also ob ich
wirklich dran ständer letztendlich bin
und die gleiche befürchtung habe ich
letztendlich auch bei dieser
namensänderung wenn jemand schon seinen
namen geändert hat dann zeigt das ja
eine gewisse seriosität
aber ob derjenige haltung wirklich trans
ist oder ob der womöglich irgendwie ja
zum beispiel ich habe also ihr
lösungsvorschlag wäre es später zu
machen erst mit 18 vielleicht oder was
ihr vorschlag also auf jeden fall erst
mit 18 das auf jeden fall und das halt
nicht zu verfrühten operationen und so
weiter kommt also ich hatte zum beispiel
im krankenhaus neben den 18 jährigen er
hat direkt mastektomie höchst direktor
rektum die zusammen gemacht da sorgt die
gebärmutter eierstock entfernung bei dem
sein arzt ihm gesagt hat dass er sonst
krebs bekommen würde und es war halt
keine weitere irgendwie erklärungen halt
darüber also gleichen war bewusst dass
er dann keine kinder kriegen kann aber
krebs ist halt irgendwie da eine gefahr
womöglich in zehn jahren habe es ist ja
nicht glauben die politik befördert das
mit dem selbstbestimmungsrecht auf jeden
fall ja also da ist der halt sehr
wichtig wenn die bei diesen
selbstbestimmung das gesetz bei jetzt
bei den verankerungen eben wie gesagt
auch kritische stimmen reichen holen
also zum beispiel trans team
sorgeberechtigt fällt mir rein haben das
ist eine vereinigung da geht es darum
dass die kinder gerade alle tradition
ihren und dieses sap add on the net ist
wir haben das wird ja immer abgestritten
dass es das gibt das heißt plötzlich
eintretende denters für ihr ab dem 14
lebensjahr ungefähr oder den 13 das
heißt diese leute die wissen eben nicht
in der kindheit wie hier mein nachbar
geschildert hat im dass sie schon trans
sind sondern ist es plötzlich haben
ungefähr der pubertät eintreten dass die
der meinung sind dass sie dran sind
häufig das ist aber als so dass sie
entdecken dass ich schwul oder lesbisch
sind und dann denken sie müssten um in
die gesellschaft zu passen als letzte
frage zu ihrem thema wie geht es ihnen
denn heute also mir jetzt auf jeden fall
wieder besser ich hatte meinen ganzen
bachelor hatte ich als mann gemacht dass
man mich sehr sehr schwierig vor allem
fand ich das schwierig werden kobelt hab
ich dann probiert zu gehen der
geotechnik und genau das hat nicht so
gut geklappt aber jetzt muss ich halt
direkt als frau angefangen klar ich habe
die ganze zeit die verwechslungen aber
wenn ich das dann richtig stellen dann
würde ich auch immer gut angenommen also
daher ja jetzt fühle ich mich nicht mehr
so als würde ich mich die ganze zeit
verstellen das finde ich super vielen
herzlichen dank dass sie die geschichte
geteilt aber ich finde das ganz wichtig
und bleiben sie da auch so kritisch und
laut